good evening everyone welcome to our
class for the viewers choice I said it
chilly you're not recording here I'm
glad that I wore Ben's favorite t-shirt
of mine but I'm glad to have my jacket
on - all right so we have Daniel colors
game here against his opponent who we
don't know who he is but I hope if he's
watching our Channel he is going to
enjoy our comments on his game he said -
Jonathan hello Jonathan I'm one of the
Watchers of your youtube series of of
Chess Club and scholastic centre of st.
Louis of course and I wanted to say I
would like your lessons I like you to
lessons very much
he had this blitz game and he want to
share it with us okay let's have a look
guys he 4 C 5 we have a Sicilian that
we're off to a good start here 93 e 6d
for 64 and 96 t for now you know
generally what what do what do we refer
to the lines were white Lee is 93 and 94
just formally do you know that it's
called open Sicilian I think that means
that white enters the main line so what
other choices white but if you play with
g3 right g3 and b3 and play the King's
Indian system with the Kings in your
system where I can play c3 transposed to
develop in or even after d5 you can play
oops
completely 5 so once white commits the
move d4 now we have this setup that is
very identifiable it's very important to
remember so why it has more of what
space right and black has a small Center
so the entire thing the entire conflict
is about if black can survive White's
assault because of the extra space then
black but he has a he or she has a
better center
mm-hmm so a six this is called Paulson
or Khan's system black doesn't want to
show his hand doesn't want to tell us
what kind of setup this is going to
choose but controls it be five square
preparing for the move b5 maybe and
planning to play the most likely chefs
if I were 96 later and also delayed them
of Knight f6 so maybe this night goes to
e7 supporting the move Knight to c6 if
you do that with 97 or 96 then a6 is
important which prevents them of 95 max
c3 obviously white can also opt for the
multiband with the most c4 right you
know about that too right
actually that would my choice if I would
recommend the line against this line I
would say this move or or a different
setup okay Knight c3 d6
so I made the comment yes it's not a bad
move but it's by itself but it gives
white the chance to choose his preferred
setup because black has not engaged in a
confident center yet white can freely
choose the setup now let me ask you guys
can instead of in this position
different setups hmm what kind of setups
white can what can build or how can i
how can you set up these pieces
basically Adi what's that tell me where
the pieces are going afford them what
with the so you want to put immediate
pressure on these six after f5 that's
one set up right the only problem is
that Bishop c4 will be met by b5
immediately that's one problem we have
to always consider ID what do you think
good same thing that's that's the only
way you know somebody just said another
system with bishop it should be should
be three and Casta what do you say about
that
that's also good oh come on what do you
think give give give me a setup whatever
you think no setup give me a move
there should be three of them Oh
actually that's the move our player
played Danielle so this actually is a
very flexible one the only thing black
managed to prevent is that the lines
with ninety of six and Bishop g5 which
are very very sharp so after the move
d6y White has this kind of silhouette
can go f4 this is one setup Queen f3
there should be three and long castle or
even with short castle with Bishop to d3
we'll see that coming so White has
different choices there he also can
white also can play Bishop III Queen d2
F 3 and g4 along Castle which is known
as the English attack or you can just
choose Bishop e2 be show you 3 and short
Castle that's the typical
like the sharing a setup or another
thing I was thinking which is not that
common is to play them of g4 well this
move if I go pressured you to and Castle
if black is plays a regular move like
Knight f6 you can go G 597 and Bishop g2
then Castle and play a4 a5 and what is
many Tempe ahead because when you played
the line with Bishop e2 and Bishop e3
and play a four then you're gonna have
to go to f3 g4 and comes to g2 you
already are winning a temple here with
the Moche for but obviously black is not
forced to play Knight f6 right can go P
597 Bishop b7 and maybe even goes h5 so
when you take the angle night goes
Knight f6 so there are more than more
than one set up here for y but I like to
smoke Bishop e3 it's kind of flexible
and it doesn't show exactly what doesn't
show his hand that I want to play f3
Queen d2 I want to play a four Queen f3
I won't play a four Bishop e2 I won't
play for Bishop d3 you know there are
many many ways to continue so knight c6
Queen to d2
I think against 96 my preferred movies
are for let me let me talk about this
move a little bit to you guys and
Danielle so what can we do here as Black
Knight of 6 and then Queen
3.now question here guys for you do we
have two casts along here for white or
not what do you think what what
after clinically what are the possible
setups for white
Bishop b2 is not a good move that's what
I wanted to talk about because you have
to enforce reinforce efore because if
you got Bishop b2 where it has eyes it's
black Timon let's say black plays Queen
c7 if you play Bishop e2 then black can
take and play b5 then you go a3 black
plays Bishop e7 you have to go Bishop d3
later right takes takes and b5 now e5
runs into Bishop e7 right so a three and
then you go Bishop e7 you have to not
defend this guy anyways - so you lose a
tempo so you are better off to put the
bishop on d3 so here you have two
choices either Bishop d3 or castle not
we should be - you may be able to start
with g4 right away but I'm not sure if
it works here because if g4 I did not
check all the details but I was worried
about this take take any five doesn't
look nice does it anything else comes in
mind I think let's look at this - hope
so Bishop d3 black cannot play b5
because yes II five so I also Bishop d7
is not a good move it's too slow so
what's the idea behind Bishop d7 I want
to take on d4 right and I want to place
the bishop on c6 huh is that right
well that's too slow because look at the
look at whites pieces he's ready to cast
on either side and he's ready to lash
out with what move g4g 45 and that
Bishop on d7 coming to c6 doesn't have
enough enough pressure on the pawn on e4
you have pressure on the pawn on e4 by
pushing the knight from c3 by playing b5
before right
you need this push the pawn push so that
you can undermine the pawn on e4 but the
bishop on d7 loses you lose three Tempe
okay to Tempe because 94 is a tempo
winning move to get there by the time
you play Bishop e5 before I manage to
play d4 g5 I've already dismissed blacks
play so it takes takes Bishop c6 and I
go g4 and probably black is close to
losing has a lot of problem I cannot go
pure b7 g 5 is coming long castle is
ballast to go g 5h for black is way way
behind in in development right so not
Bishop d7 Bishop e7 and now I go short
castle
I checked the move long castle but I
don't think if you want to play long
castle on g4 you don't need to move your
bishop from f1 if you wanted you go
right here so if I'm right now I'm
talking about this setup with Bishop d3
and castle right so if you won't play
the long castle idea you call long cast
on good start with g4 you don't need to
put the bishop on d3 there because there
the bishop either can go to g2 or h3
right so the bishop after g4 belongs to
one of these two square to support
either pressing on a scissor or
controlling the for each risk or a four
square
so Bishop d3 Bishop goes to e7 short
Castle short Castle King Quechuan I'm
not sure again this this was the most to
Caesarea move but okay
I cannot lick Winnie Street right I
cannot is that right because of not
first first takes takes and then 25 I'm
losing a piece King catch one but I
can't prepare this idea g4g five for
example Bishop d7 look a e19 planning to
take on c6 and maybe play queen h3 and
and somehow giv d5 maybe b5 a three
Brooke a b8 now black is preparing them
of before take and then he wants to put
pressure here
Knight c6 Bishop c6 and queen h3 now
what are we trying to do here if I've
right I have a rope d8 Bishop drops back
to d2 this is the game I think Kamsky
against mahadji are awfully somewhere so
rook T it also prevents if I've right
here okay an account of an account of
this tak tacular sure will be met with
this
so here coughs we played this one
preparing them on e5 again d5 b 594 and
now what do you think Kamsky did however
if i give you guys two some time to
think about it huh I'll let everyone
also who is watching us from home we are
here in st. Lucia's Club viewers game
Daniel Kohler sent us this beautiful
game now fears we're not following the
main line yet but I thought I should
share this knowledge of Sicilian with
everyone before we go to the main line
now we're looking at the game shamsky
against my musharraf I think from the
2013 World Cup in Tromso in Norway so I
give you everyone a few minutes to think
about it
what's blacks biggest problem basically
so was white brown what's a black power
we are on white to move the accounts
came up with a very very strong idea of
blacks problem is that he does he have
enough defense on the kingside
everything seems to be to have shifted
to the Queen side or the center-right do
do our viewers have some questions for
me
eat bishop is blonde yeah and already
says we have to open the bishop Joel
says the night is pin then neither
Spencer's yeah that's why we play them
of f5 did you guys consider them over
five
well the question is that
well should we consider this mover five
because what about if I take the bishop
right now a lot of people may think f6
but then a knight goes back to e4 and
then we have to we have to give up our
our bit pawn after f6 we have to give up
our pawn and our attack is gone this
point is weak but here's here's couch
this brilliant idea F takes c6 now we're
attacking h7 taking mate so that has to
go back to e4 e f7 check King there and
then Knight takes d5 another a good move
Bishop to e5 and our rook takes e4 and
not a brilliant move Bishop before runs
into a checkmate
after g6 this position white is better I
do not want to discuss further from this
point this one because it takes another
20 minutes and I want to spend time on
Daniels game talking about that but why
it's advantage is decisive here so
that's one set up okay going for it with
the concentration of the pieces in the
center and the Queen's King side and
then going with the attack and the other
set up here is the move a long castle
that was Todd's favorite setup in in in
60s and early 70s which should be seven
and then takes takes and then g4 d v g5
right there and the niche for with a
very complex and interesting position I
like to be white but this is a complex
position
all right any questions so far
let's go back to our games so Daniel
chose the English setup that's fine also
this prevents them of 94 have to
consider this one Queen c7 and here you
played P Sheree - no no no no when you
go with this setup although in some line
they play with Sheree - then that's okay
but when you go with the setup
you really want to Castle and then
attack g4 g5 which for as soon as you
can okay Bishop UT will be a very tough
time well what happened is this after
Bishop b2 Bishop e7 now what do we have
to do here guys what shouldn't we do
actually that's the first thing we have
to answer what's more we should avoid in
this position we'll be statically
incorrect for white it's a no-no and
Daniel should Daniel and you guys should
remember that from now on do we have any
answer from our viewers
uh-huh
well Jafar is not that bad actually
he should not Castle that's what Daniel
did you should not Castle because
because you don't have any active fly
now the bishop is on it you already it
will cost the temple to move the Bishop
to d3 it takes another temple to do what
I need to do what that pawn on f3 which
will surely be when you're short
castling won't you short castle worship
that Pompey on f2 or where f4 yes so
that's not a temple and the queen is not
going to f3 to h3 so we don't have that
as well we will take luck almost forever
to build our setup and if we just stay
then black and build his attack so black
castle why play 93 actually this is a
wise decision he kind of tries to stop
opponents from activity and then here
now here black starts to make mistakes
so black play the move Bishop to d7 and
as you can see I said b5 yp5 is much
more important than the move Bishop d7
this is very important to understand
because the idea behind the movie 5 and
roots in the initial thing I said about
it White has more on what space and
black has a small Center there now did
white uses this extra space he did not
write why did not seize the initiative
why didn't try anything act active duty
hmm make sense guys so because why
didn't write anything for anything
active now black can come up with the
move B 5
I'll never happen what happens then the
bishop comes to be seven the night goes
to d5 2.c4 where do we put the rooks the
8 has see it right and then d5 and then
I released power of my center and I gave
more space and in the meantime why
doesn't have any active plan in fact
maybe it was better
actually now I change my mind maybe
first a 4 and then 93 just to stop that
pawn move ok but luckily Bishop d7 so
again it's a waste of time because when
you go b5 you still eat the bishop on
the a a - h1 diagonal so that you can
play d6 to d5 that's the idea that gives
it enough space and opens the line in
blacks favor
so Daniel played a reasonably good
mohawk a d1 also another question
another question this one I want you
guys to give me an answer which file is
more important C file or the D file
everyone one minute
okay Maddy what do you think if the
death not defiled you mean okay the old
what do you think da or C fault default
for white C file for black which one is
more important it's an open file right
the D is open for wise and C is open for
black the file for white is more
important as CFR for black then do we
have answers from our viewers Julie
Jaeger says they're both open C C is
open for black D is open for white
alright T was for D okay everybody knows
that everybody knows about this general
idea that the central files are more
important only if the center is open the
C file is more valuable to black than
the D file because central pawns because
for the most part in the opening pieces
are have concentration in the center
right the politics is livid out of rich
but the knight on c3 is reachable with
the pawn on b b7 and also after after
that Knight moves away we can put more
pressure on the policy too because the
knight on c3 is very valuable it stops
the move d5 so the knight cannot move
making it a target for black in Sicilian
defense especially in the lions white
castles King side the C file is more
valuable than D file
almost 90 percent of the time so
occupying the D file doesn't do enough
for white unless he launches an attack
on the King side any comments about that
pen
nothing they were still talking about
the CND smile earlier
RJ Aguilar says the center always not
this time all right
this is this was one of the first
lessons I learned from the first
training camp I went basically it was by
Alexa Koosman that was that was that's
where I learned that okay see file is
more important b5 so now when you look
at the board guys we like to have our
Bishop on b7 right already sounds wrong
so a three it's a good move to prevent
the move before look 88 is that the
place for the rook now Rock belongs to C
it
why because C family the other who can't
go to d8 and then C for soft we could go
look a c8 then look ft 895 even fish
supposed to eat it and then prepare them
of the or c6 and then prepare them of d5
and the Night Elves can go to c4 after
the trade will win the two bishops and
then we can gradually improve our
position without any risk which is a
five before a fight before an ultimately
d5 that's what blood wants to do look 88
that's not a good move
so after wasting few ten people buy
black now Daniel got his chance it made
a good move f4 excellent move good job
Daniel 7 let's give us give him a a next
clamp yoo-hoo
good mouth prevents fg5 first of all
because not the fact could be met with
d5 right well I'm not talking about if
you can take on d5 or not but in general
now we're not worried about the v as
much because we always have B 5 reply
here which makes it even stronger with
that Bishop on d7 because when the
bishop is RC it or B 7 after defiantly 5
you can play the move Knight f6 to d7
right but now with that Bishop on d7 d5
we fight that the poor knight on f6 has
has nowhere to go
another reason why the bishop on d7 does
not make sense bishop said good move
black confesses to his mistake and
problem plays the smoke and and Daniel
okay another move Bishop e3 was also
possible with the idea g4 g g5 of course
we have to check if the move d5 is
possible or not it might be possible I
feel it should be possible but okay
Queen e1 good enough get the Queen out
out of the way and now this Queen can be
in route to h3 actually now we may have
actually an attack now sounds good right
and likely Bishop e7
now how many time how many 10 people are
lost Bishop d7 Bishop c8 that's to Tempe
to Tempe there right and I look 88 the
rook should move from da to see it now
three Tempe that gave white enough time
to play on a4 and bring the Queen to the
game now we have it not a typical
opening position by the typical Sicilian
position now White's plan as I've shown
here Bishop d3 Queen Sherri and the
movie 5 that's what he wants to do
I should add after Queen you sure you
also have always the idea of G 45 and
that left first
d5 I think the move before was very
interesting and I just check my ideas
with the computer so it's not follow
computer analysis but I was just
checking a tactic so take stakes and I
realize now why it is very much in the
game so look at this f5 now what does y
want to do here
takes their 98 now what can we do here
as white while I take and then play
Queen b6 check take your brush at
nighttime b3 check the tactics I'll give
everyone like three minutes two or three
minutes to think about this position you
see what is behind the tempo of having
the king on h1 because that's the move
that gets the King out of all this
chicks in all this counter place so but
the move you have to check is what is
the move f6 so guys what happens after
f6 take rook takes Queen b6 check
any comments says who uh-huh says f6
well what's the follow-up we need a
follow-up Bishop takes rook takes Queen
b6 check there's a knight on it my
friend there's a knight on the 8th
there's a there is it there's a big big
night sitting down down here it's not a
good night but it's to the night well I
said well have we set after six but
what's the follow-up Bishop takes rook
takes Queen b6 chick and I take that
night on b3 and it'll be down to pawns
and there's no media checkmate so you
guys have to see further if you train
with your coaches you have to sit here
spend countless number of minutes I
don't know if I can give you hours I
mean back in my time we were doing hours
you didn't have good engines to check
these lines so we're trying to analyze
and calculate ourselves so we would
become stronger players first first
first move e5 or after if six after my
line
area says f6 Bishop takes rook f6 no but
the thing is that the assume will take
back with the knight on f6 no we did not
take back on f6 Bishop f6 rook F 6 Queen
b6 check and then we grab the knight on
v3
okay any more comments ill please says
first new eb-5 now first of all is f6
everybody who said if 6 is right but you
have to not calculate the follow-up all
right I'll show some few moves this
check alright now we have this position
all right guys any ideas any comments
now that's funny it gets complicated in
fact when I first look at this position
I thought Weiss attack is going to
fizzle out and black is winning but
that's not the case now we have a second
target okay
can you spot that second target for what
g7 is not the main target anymore
okay any comments
no comments this is tough rock f3 very
strong move
in fact it deserves to exclam in my
opinion a very natural move but the idea
behind it is very important after this
move black just can play King h8 right
well taking MB mm really help because I
wanna go Queen eh - Queen h4 now
attacking you're looking rook g3 so King
catch it now we sacrifice on g7 Knight
takes Queen h4 now I simply plan to play
rock h3 and checkmate on at 7 and black
doesn't have a reasonable defense
against it so looks like game over
makes sense guys any comments any
questions about that online no all right
now what about Queen b6 now we know
where the target is let's keep going
with it Queen h4 now we are finding the
motorcoach three f6 now black is
preparing to play rook one of the rooks
of seven covering gauge seven right make
sense guys Neil you're following and
you're following okay Bishop takes g7
because I don't want a rook take on g7
because if you're Luke sits on on the
seventh rank then H 7 will be defended
permanently and our attack is gone so
it's time for us to take on g7 and 9700
three three I didn't find a concrete win
but White has a very very strong attack
might be winning actually so this
explains to us that wife was very much
back into the game and that in fact
White was not ahead from black in terms
of the attack because black wasted so
much time
then why species are now very strong and
very very much ready for the attack on
the King side let's go back to the game
that's not what happened in the game we
had the move d5 y play the move e5
probably black should have played 94
trying just to trade but black played
night well or at least 97 98 that's not
a good move guys do not voluntarily put
your night and this on the back rank
between your rocks don't just don't do
that okay it's a blitz game there are so
many factors involved maybe black fat he
can play g6 and 97 and then put the
night on f5 but that takes forever we
don't have that much time in terms of
that much of luxury that much time so at
this moment black lady move white
palladium of night to d4 it's a natural
move but I think the most queen of two
was probably more annoying because now
what's our threat playing we should be
six
Quincy ate and now we got Bishop g4 then
our plan is quite simple my T to c3 and
then place the knight on d4 and then we
could gradually prepare for the move to
f5
I check few few few continue in here
black is really out of chance to to
react to this one easily any questions
all right
so 94 my ship C 596 this is just fine
now White has typical advantage good
Bishop on a good Bishop only to bad
Bishop on c6 the first score at vice
disposal and White has a clear plan
attacking blacks King but you have to do
it with care and caution and patience
how do you group White's pieces okay
this is a very very nice study actually
instead I mean it's a nice exercise it's
a very nice exercise to understand what
you'd word you the pieces belong to we
take our time to build to build the best
setup to set the pieces the right place
and then launch the attack because in
the game Daniel played them over five
and if I was not the most likely move he
played exceptionally well especially
after black gave him almost MP and I was
back to the game and he got this huge
advantage because black with a lot of
crevice moves and ended up having this
this French defense position where the
good where black has lost his good be
sure which is a dark square bishop and
end up with the bad bishop on c6 but the
night hunt the knight doesn't belong to
c3 the bishop doesn't belong to e2 how
do we how do we recruit White's pieces
how are you I give you guys three
minutes here
any comments
that's okay they are on a 25 second
delay okay
Darth Belichick says followed by guys I
follow up don't give me a move give me a
plan followed by what Bishop f3 word to
word do white pieces belong to how do
you rewrite your knight how do you
rewrite your Bishop how you set up your
pieces before trying to play a move f5
because a5 at this moment it doesn't
earn you enough because the bishop on d2
doesn't do anything it doesn't attack
blacks King it doesn't target anything
right so doesn't the knight on c3 you
need some sort of a harmony among your
pieces before you launch an attack
Bishop d3 90 92 94 maneuver is great
there's a problem you can apply Bishop
to Bishop d3 there's d4 and after Queen
to h3 you go g6 so you don't get to play
what you want to there's a tactical
problem with it otherwise that was the
best that was the best setup and that is
a dream setup so maybe maybe you have to
change the move order and you can get
the same thing but that's the best setup
the knight on d4 the bishop on d3 that's
what you want to get the questions are
how to get it
okay a lot of people are saying here the
obvious target is h7 so they want to go
after 87 Raths proposes look at
free-swinging over to h3 that that
wouldn't work because we have three
rounds into d4 guys your opponent also
has moves too you cannot just think
about your plan [ __ ] h3 deny God e4
again yeah
no comment daddy no comment all right
okay
so what was what was the dream setup
Eddie I I just mentioned that what was
the dream setup tell me where do I want
to put in item Bishop on I mentioned the
dream setup for white f4 come on knight
on d4 right knight on d4 bishop on d3 I
can't do it right away so I do this way
I got Bishop f3 Queen B 792 night C 794
and then I rewrite the bishop and then C
3 and then I shift the pieces to the
attack that was the necessary just take
your time we ship every night cause once
you have tonight on d4 it's easier to
rewrite the bishop back to d3 alright so
anyways
Daniel played a five it kind of lets go
of his advantage but the game gets is a
very interesting out it takes a five or
six a five Queen B seven g6 was more
meaningful I guess a 97 right or a five
right
so here what goes roopd for actually
this is awesome a meaningful move
stuffing this Bishop and also trying to
sorry this is the color and then
pre-plan I'm trying to reroute the rook
to the other side so g6 here comes the
the first mistake
so should I play rook f3 oh I'm actually
have to play this one and here black
blade Knight - is that what he played c7
the move Knight g7 was necessary
and the game would end in a draw and a
crazy way the game of the game and it
will end in a trial let me explain a
little bit Bishop g4 because of
ninety-six Bishop d7 takes takes takes
takes takes and the rook to e8 look back
t4 and roof height H 5 g 4 and R of T 2
and then repetition that is a crazy line
you have to go through it because I'm a
little bit short on time I have to show
you some more tactics to think about but
that would have been the possible way to
end for the game to end in a draw
obviously a mark 2 and jeans or two
strong teams not in a bliss game so here
black with Knight c7 does this move
makes sense guys it does not right
you're moving tonight away from the king
I understand the knight wants to land on
e6 but now we have a golden opportunity
what is the golden opportunity guys
anybody's shouting a line
then I go a5 after that the Queen will
defend also Queen e86 I can go Queen b6
first so you go to cache for wreckage 3
which one
any comments
now he Plateau catch three but every
catch four is this is the right move
because obviously default loses to
create six right tonight is f5 here at
five is force but then I take the pawn
and the rook is defending now the pawn
because otherwise black doesn't have a
but in the game he played for coach
three black played ninety six and after
Queen to h6 which is a blunder actually
that the funny thing is that here the
right move is not ninety six this is
also a mistake I forgot to mention here
the right move is a five
majority is rogue age for yes majority
yes that's the right book so location
three here here after this move he made
this planet we need six by brocade seven
is a silhouetting takes takes and I
think that's one thing a lot of time
people can miss this kind of tactics and
I remember this if I if I ever miss this
kind of tactic it's because I forget
about check here here and I can forget
about this check Queen takes f6 a lot of
time in our calculations guys we forget
about this kind of checks when a pawn
runs into or a pawn or a piece runs in
runs under your attack and you forgot
that at some point you can take that
with a check and then you can take on e6
take on g6 you take everything basically
g6 is 6
c6 everything ok here he blundered and
plenty nice six oh that's sad for Daniel
what you know I really appreciate he
chose this game because this is this was
very insightful very we learned a lot
from this game so it's a pollen play 5 a
good move open the Queen and now
attacking the rook now but still entire
project gets very interesting now here I
will catch for now what's the winning
move for black guys those pieces are not
doing anything why species lack
coordination
well then I take and take on it seven
any comments
no yes no okay the winning movies d4
guys opens the diagonal attacks the
night and I worried about taking on it
seven takes six to nine is hanging and
then take next move take on Jeju black
Farouk f7 that is a yes because yeah and
what Daniel again missed it
oh my god probably both had a few
seconds left on the clock
this is winning right it's a checkmate
ah that's sad right safely there won't
be sheepish five oh my god now she takes
h5 and then he missed Queen takes c6 oh
my god they probably didn't have any
time that this moment and okay but it
gets interesting we catch 597 I don't
know why I didn't take on h7 or queen g5
Dean take on it seven check now is
losing he play Knight he played check
there and play 92 here I think black
check can just take on e2 and wins but I
don't know why I play d4 not the pawn g2
is well defended so he played a good
move Knight g1 covering the King and
also g2 Zoo defended another 96 here he
blundered coinage a check after Queen g6
the game is still unclear
because my g5 is not possible because
our okay Shea check King g7 and point x
g5 which is losing a for black so after
Queen juice is the game would have
remained unclear so now somebody can ask
me why I chose this game why do you
think I chose this game first of all
Daniel sent us a game what she lost
he thought that he can learn a lot from
this game and that's why I chose this
game because he laughter so I plays
beautiful sacrifice and it's okay you
can't share it but when you have a very
beautiful game that is one-sided or
you're showing one one specific idea
there isn't enough to share so when you
share at least with me your games said
not a muscle incentive the games you're
losing but send the ones that has most
amount of questions most more number of
mistakes so that we can all go over and
we can learn from those right that's
very important always a game that's
interesting to watch that has a lot of
important decisions in it and usually we
end up having a lot of inaccurate moves
in them which is fine because we the
intention is to learn so that's the kind
of games it's good to choose to learn
from I will not have the time to cover
it in this lecture but and next lecture
I will start with that one before I
continue with the with the with the
viewers choice and that would be the
I'll show you the last win of Capablanca
with like this against Lasker where
Alaska tried to play the same kind of
style with just piece maneuver against
the Sicilian defense and he demonstrated
how the idea of d5 could be dangerous
but that game will take some time to
look at so how do we have some time been
are you going into the Romantic era well
I mean I wanted to continue with both I
just need a few minutes break between
the two we can I mean I just wanted to
see that I can get a few minutes break
between the two and then I'll continue
with the put the next one same about an
hour okay so I'm gonna go over this one
that's fine I'll make that much shorter
okay
okay sounds good all right so I'll make
this one a bit longer all right they
don't want to care about okay so no I'm
just wrapping this one up right this one
and then we continue with the Romantic
choice so here's the game kappa blanka
against Lasker here's the training mode
so Sicilian defense and as I can okay
the most are not accurate I'm not going
to discuss the accuracy of the moves in
the opening so as you can see even last
couple is more active you play with them
over four but again the formation of the
pieces is not good okay if he goes long
castle is actually fine but he goes for
he goes for short castle and he start
playing with the piece he starts playing
with the pieces piece Mona were not such
fun stuff this will not not get anywhere
if he do not involve the pawns if you do
not engage the pawns to attack Buda not
good not good anywhere and now let's
look at what come over Lanka did he
played any five get improves his
position on the other side of the board
and brings the rook to see a square now
puts a lot of pressure on the White
Queen side plays not yet I don't think
it's a good enough I think the move
Bishop eh with 97 is a better man you
work and take on the 704 endpoint 97
because the closer you get to the end
game because of those paths of those
advanced pawns on the Kings and the
Queen side black has more chances to put
pressure on White's position and the
pawn on g7 Luke could be easily handled
with a king if the bishops would
get traded so 98 and I take stakes f-5e
595 Quinby 755 f6 and I simply builds up
the IDF 95 and now the position becomes
irresistible just fundamentally the pawn
structure is bad and what is what is
simply lost and kappa blanka mass
massively converted into a full point
okay again the game is from Moscow
International 1936 actually is 35 now 36
35 a couple local didn't play so well
alright so we'll give you a few minutes
break maybe a couple of nice program we
continue with the with Romantic era
[Music]
you
you